les robots ont la cote à montréal on
attendait de 500 inscriptions pour cet
événement international sur la robotique
il y en a déjà au dessus de 4000 qu'on
s'attend à peut-être devoir fermer les
portes à se rendre jusqu'à la limite de
5000 donc une énorme édition pourra
croire des chercheurs qui viennent de
partout à travers le monde
l'industrie adopté les robots depuis
plusieurs années par souci d'économie et
les pénuries de main d'oeuvre et rendre
encore plus attrayant ce troisième bras
développé par l'université de sherbrooke
permet de faire de travail de deux
personnes
si j'ai besoin des mme carmen pour faire
une tâche mais là maintenant je vais
avoir une deuxième paire de brogues mais
des exemples donnés repas noah
maintenant de brûler dans le mur surtout
dans un contexte de pénurie de main
d'oeuvre comme on connaît deux villes
soit population qui nous veut est un
pionnier québécois dans la conception de
bras robotisé celui-ci était
initialement destiné aux personnes
handicapées mais il trouve maintenant
d'autres utilités l'outil qu'on a
développé pour ces personnes-là le robot
en fin de compte eu des débouchés dans
plusieurs autres marchés
on avait démarré très fort dans le
médical la chirurgie la réadaptation
mais aussi on est entré dans le monde
industriel beaucoup grâce à la recherche
même les artistes parcellaires ou
gothique comme dans cette installation
l'idée c'est de faire une chaîne de
montage qui fabrique des châteaux de
sable qui sont détruits quand y'en marre
et donc avec la position de la lune
donc le convoyeur démarre le château est
détruit donc c'est comme la crise les
prouesses des robots sont de plus en
plus impressionnante mais suscite
parfois des craintes qui a toujours
énormément de recherches sur leur
autonomie commanderont systèmes
robotiques le plus autonome possible
beaucoup d'applications réelles
évidemment auquel on peut penser autant
l'industrie qui ont réponse aux mesures
d'urgence qui requiert l'expert qui est
l'opérateur
selon une étude plus du tiers des
emplois pourraient potentiellement être
remplacés par des robots d'ici 20 ans la
robotique va toutefois créer de nouveaux
emplois spécialisés il faut bien
quelqu'un pour s'occuper des robots ici
michel marsolais radio canada montréal